-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actress
you know her from her work
on shows like
"Parks and Recreation"
and FX's "Legion."
She stars in "Black Bear,"
which is in select theater
and on VOD now.
Let's take a look.
-I think I'm into traditiona
gender roles.
Yeah. No, I really --
I mean that.
I don't know.
Can't say a part of me doesn't
want a man to just come alon
and take care of everything.
-Doesn't that kind of contradict
your entire life?
What about your films?
Don't you think
they're feminist?
-I don't think about them
one way or the other.
-You don't think about them?
How can you make something
if you never think about it?
-Sometimes when you're makin
something, you're not --
-I'm talking to her.
-Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend,
Aubrey Plaza.
How are you, Aubrey?
-I'm fine.
How are you, Seth?
-Do you enjoy the Zoom
press, or...?
I obviously would prefer
if you were here,
but do you like the Zoom
element of it?
-I mean, yeah, kind of.
Although I do feel that
Zoom fatigue is real.
-Yeah.
-Like, I think it's
actually real.
Every night I am passing out
at 9:00 p.m.
because I think my brain
is so stimulated
by this -- future Zooms.
-Yeah, also you just spend
too much of the day
looking at yourself, which I
think is, like, exhausting
-It's not healthy, it's no
healthy for any of us.
I don't know, I don't --
I don't know.
Screens, robots, they're all
coming for us, Seth.
-This movie is getting
fantastic reviews.
You are outstanding in it.
It is --
-Thank you.
-The three of you,
because it's
basically a three-hander,
it's just a wonderful
kind of film to watch
because you're all so wonderful,
and there's incredible
shifts in it.
It seems like it might have been
an exhausting movie to mak
just because of how,
I don't know,
like, the emotional hoops
you all jump through.
Was that the case?
-Yes, it was.
It was...
We were shooting in a very
remote location
in middle of nowhere
in the Adirondacks,
and all night shoots
for 20 days, and I think,
yeah, I think I totally
lost my mind.
And I think physically
it was very demanding.
I was -- I kind of --
My character is, like, basically
wasted for half of the movie
so I was just
in a constant state of just --
I mean, you know how that is
just being so drunk
that you can't walk upstairs
without flinging your body
against a wall.
-Yeah, it's like my move.
-It's just your every night.
But, like, I --
Yeah, I was really --
it was very, very exhausting
but it felt like --
it was also very joyful
and it felt --
I don't know, it was just --
Christopher Abbott
and Sarah Gadon are so talente
and I think the three of us just
banded together like a weird
[bleep] family and we just
got through it together.
And it was fun,
but in a very dark way.
-Yeah, I've been a fan
of Christopher's.
I had never seen Sarah before.
She's just excellent as well
When you mention night shoots,
you know, I think people
can appreciate that means
you're shooting at night,
but I think what people forget
is that means you have to go
back to the real world
at, like, 6:00 in the morning.
Like, where were you staying
when you shoot
at remote place like this?
-Yeah, so we were staying --
So, Chris, Sarah, and I
were staying
in little town called
Saranac Lake,
which was about
an hour drive from set.
And we carpooled together
because the movie had no money
the budget was really small.
And so we would drive back
to Saranac
basically as the sun
was coming up,
and -- which was our night
And I remember, like,
you know,
just to do something normal,
you know, besides shooting
I would walk around the town
or get a cup of coffee
or whatever, or sit in the par
across from the hotel.
And I looked so insane
I think most people in the tow
thought I was like
a crazy street person
that had, like, moved in.
And I didn't fight it.
I just leaned into it.
And I became this townie.
Just -- just --
I looked --
Yeah, I can't explain it.
I looked on another level
of insane.
-I'd like to think ever
since you left,
I would like to think
the legend if you in the tow
is that you got your act
together.
Like, for three weeks we had
this crazy woman,
but then I think
she cleaned herself up.
-I cleaned myself up,
I started acting career
and just immediately got cas
in two films that came out
in the same week.
Typical rags to riches story
-The other film,
"Happiest Season,"
which was a delight,
you filmed in Pittsburgh.
Did you enjoy --
I mean, we like to talk abou
Pittsburgh here
as much as possible.
Did you enjoy
that wonderful city?
-Yes, yes, I loved it.
And I'm from, you know,
Delaware/Philadelphia.
So there was a lot
of crossover there,
I feel like, with Philly and -
[Bleep] I can't remember
the famous sandwich place.
-Primanti Brothers.
-Primanti Brothers?
-Yeah, right?
The french fries
on the sandwich?
-Yes, yes, french fries
on the sandwich.
Did that.
And I learned very quickly
that Pittsburgh has, like,
the most amount
of dive bars or the most
amount of bars,
I guess, in their city.
-Yeah, it's a pretty bar city.
-It's crazy.
So that was very fun.
And we frequented
a lot of those places.
And also, just the city
is beautiful.
I never -- I had never bee
there, so I didn't realize
like -- it was almost European
with all the bridges
and the waterways,
and I loved it.
I'd love to go back there.
-I want to also -- You mentioned
that you're from Delaware.
I do feel like people
from who are from Delaware
also always say
a second place.
Like, "I'm from
Delaware/Philadelphia."
But this is a big time
for Delaware.
-Okay, I'm not belittling --
-I mean, we have
a Delaware president.
Are you very excited about that?
-Yes, I love Joe.
I love --
I'm very, very
excited about it.
I was campaigning for him.
I was out there.
And I really feel --
I've known him
since I was 16.
I don't know him well, but I met
him when I was a teenager,
and I think most people
in Wilmington have met him
at one point or the other.
He's just that kind of guy
he's very approachable.
And I'm just psyched.
Like, I think it's cool.
And Delaware's never
had a president,
so it's, like, about time.
We're the first state, you know,
if you didn't know that.
We signed --
we got on there first.
We were like,
"Yeah, we'll be a state."
And it's just a big moment
for my hometown,
so I'm very excited about it
-If someone said,
"I'm going to Wilmington.
Where should I go?"
Where would you tell them?
Because I feel like Primanti
Brothers is a perfect exampl
of where you tell someone
to go if they're in Pittsburgh
What is the equivalent
in Wilmington?
-Okay, I guess
the equivalent...
I mean, honestly, there's...
Delaware is the kind of plac
you have to find your own --
You have to find your own fun.
[ Laughter ]
Um, one --
One thing that I used to d
growing up,
and I think the kids
still do it these days,
it's called
cruising the Pike.
-Uh-huh.
-This basically means
you get in your car and you just
drive up and down Route 202,
which is called Concorde Pike.
There's just a bunch
of strip malls.
-That's great.
-You got your standard --
-So it's basically
like an escape room?
-Yes, but sometimes
I would wear giant --
I would wear giant
bear costumes
or different costumes
and I would just stand
on the side of the highway
and just wave.
You know, you have to be
creative there.
A lot of [bleep] goes down
in the Wawa parking lot.
I would suggest going
to the Wawa parking lot
and I would also suggest going
to Trolley Square,
which is where a bunch
of bars are,
and that is a real scene.
Trolleywood is what
we're calling it now.
-Well, you've painted
a beautiful picture.
-Oh, yes.
-It is always so nice
to see you.
Congrats on both films
and I hope to see you soon
-Thank you, Seth.
Thank you so much for having me.
-[ Laughing ]
-I love you so much
and I just --
I really -- I miss you.
I miss you.
And I wish I could come to
New York and see you sometime.
-"Black Bear" is in select
theaters and on VOD now.
We'll be back with
more "Late Night."